did we do a little a little costume
change
um
i'm not wearing a costume i'm wearing
dolce gabbana
it's called an evening gown darling
this is not no one's paying me for this
i paid for it it's custom thank you time
of death for me right now you look
gorgeous i'm not an acting gig this is
my life
this what fame looked like
this was success looked like
this what money looked like this is what
it looked like it's what it looked like
what is your book coming out called this
what it looked like and i will just read
the entire that book's not coming no
time soon but i curse you with joy will
be out in november okay okay and later
the last black unicorn will be out next
month i'm doing so much right now okay
i'm just you know trying to accomplish a
lot of things before 50.
what are you doing well i'm wondering
something i'm here with no shoes on i'm
jealous no shoes on i'm here's the thing
i'm from chicago
and you out here but no shoes on this is
warm weather to me i know it's hot out
here to you right
okay i appreciate you you know you know
i gotta ask you i'm uncomfortable i'm
not but you know i got out because
you're not wearing no heels you
comfortable in the mud
i'm uncomfortable but i look good
that's what it looked like
was would you define tonight as
uncomfortable
no i would define tonight as a success
it was a great night tonight okay what
did you of all i seen a man
stand up for his wife
which we don't see that much anymore
that made me have hope
how about you
i wanted you to tell about it i wanted
your opinion on it because you're a
comedian and so it was that thing where
like was that joke too far how did you
feel about what will did because you are
someone who's done comedy and yet like
you just said you saw a man defending
his wife yeah i wanna know how you felt
about would you want your husband to do
that for you if you was clearly hurt i
mean they put her face up on the screen
he looked over at his wife she was hurt
what would you want
i would want him to defend me the only
the thing that made me sad was like this
was a big night for will and then you
saw that emotion for him and it was like
it's just i can't i don't think i've
still processed how this night went you
know
well
i just know she better take care of
business when they get home
because i know i would if my man did
that for me i'm just saying
yellow
did you talk to either of them tonight
yeah i did okay did you tell them how
you felt oh they know how i feel oh they
know how that's my friends they know
well you go way back with them to that
to some of this it's a girl's trip yes
yeah they know my crazy you know yeah
well it was incredible to watch will up
there t1 how did you feel watching him
give that speech i felt very proud
i felt gratified
and i just hope that more men are like
that
care about their families
now it's not just about you right it's
not just about you sir what about your
family the people you create the people
that help you be who you are
that's important
that's what i think america forgot about
what do you say to people who are
critiquing him online right now
yeah what you doing for your family
who you protect
okay by the way can you what can we
expect from the book because we all want
to read it
but you know what you think what you
think i curse you with joy
what you think you gonna get out of that
you think you about to get the tea honey
are you thirsty you ready for some tea
time
read that book
that part she ready now i gotta go take
these [ __ ] i got a limited time on my
feet i see you already took your shoes
off what about my feet
what about my feet i want your feet to
feel good girl if you see my feet right
now they start talking to you
they be like
cali
cali shook me they girl they talking
indiana jones on the temple of them okay
i got to get i got stuck up